[Music]
reach the third I just don't believe
someone would be that Wicked because of
a disability doesn't ring true to me not
sure critique of Shakespeare is it
doesn't ring true
[Music]
oh no you've had issues
the younger one's a chance to shine well
you want people are good at being under
40 I will admit I am struggling there
but so are you don't do anything
impetuous that's all I ask we need your
wages too
foreign
titles I'll take them which ones all of
them you haven't answered a call so you
haven't answered our text what have you
been doing you must be the rich of the
third Society I'd like to join
it's great there's mortal remains are
lost to history I know
it's starting to sound slightly mad if
you could just understand the way it's
made me feel I feel energized I feel
happy
I know you're some sort of apparition
I've been trying to work out why you're
here I wonder if it's because you're
lost
how can you possibly find him on your
own finding a needle in a haystack would
be easier this is starting to look a bit
like an unhealthy Obsession plenty of
tried to find him and failed I know you
haven't been to work for the last two
weeks you tell me what that letter
represents just means reserved
I believe this is a very important
historical site this is the equivalent
of someone with a homemade rocket saying
they're going to reach the moon
you can't stop now have faith in your
research have faith in yourself
wide I won't find you
don't let them push your arm stay strong
I'm here today to tell you a story about
a person who has judged unfairly in life
I've never given the opportunity to show
their true potential
you didn't happen to know where you are
do you might help